ONE OF THOSE FIRST, LIKE,
BOY-GIRL PARTIES,
AND THERE ARE NO PARENTS THERE,
AND YOU'RE LIKE,
"COOL RANCH DORITOS?
COOKIE KRISP?"
I MEAN, WE'RE HAVING FUN.
WE'RE GOING AFTER IT.
I'M LIKE 4'9".
I'M LIKE A STRAIGHT-UP
LITTLE BOY,
I GO TO TALK
TO MY FRIEND LIZZIE,
WHO IS THIS GIRL
THAT I HAD A CRUSH ON.
LIKE, I WAS GONNA BE LIKE,
"HEY, DID YOU READ THAT ARTICLE
IN HIGHLIGHTS MAGAZINE?"
AND LIZZIE IS
SITTING THERE, LOOKING AT ME,
LIKE, UGH,
THIS GUY'S THE WORST.
AND THIS GIRL JENNY,
WHOSE HOUSE IT WAS,
COMES UP
FROM BEHIND
AND PANTSES ME
BECAUSE THERE WAS THAT YEAR,
LIKE, SEVENTH GRADE,
WHERE PANTSING WAS AN EPIDEMIC.
SO JENNY PULLS DOWN
MY LITTLE GAP KIDS KHAKIS,
BUT HERE IS THE REAL PROBLEM,
WAS THAT I WAS ALSO WEARING
SILK BOXER SHORTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF I THOUGHT
I WAS LIKE A TINY HUGH HEFNER.
[jazz music]
THE SMOOTHNESS OF THE SILK
AGAINST THE SMOOTHNESS
OF MY LITTLE BOY PENIS,
EVERYTHING COMES DOWN,
AND I'M JUST NOW BUCK NAKED.
MY LIFETIME CHILDHOOD CRUSH
LIZZIE IS STARING STRAIGHT
AT ME
AND MY TINY, LITTLE CASHEW.
THE GIRL WHO PANTSED ME,
SHE'S TRAUMATIZED,
LIZZIE IS TRAUMATIZED,
I AM NOW A COMEDIAN.